is speaking out about his decision to
take a break from tick-tock yeah sean
appeared at the we can survive concert
over the weekend which benefits the
american foundation for suicide and
prevention and revealed to odyssey he
became addicted to social media
tick tock is great i mean it's it's it's
definitely
like i have a extreme social media
addiction so like i
have to really balance myself out like i
have to delete those apps like every now
and again yeah i'm on a tick tock break
right now
when i have it it's everything what's
your for your page look like what's the
most
a lot of singers yeah i'm a lot of
singers
oh
this is a topic okay jojo how much time
do you spend on social media and do you
have tick tock uh yeah
okay so here's my thing i'm not as good
as at social media as i probably should
be um
and i was on take i'm i am on tick tock
you can find me georgia mason music but
i posted videos of myself singing and
doing the thing and and doing the tick
tock stuff and then i posted a video of
my cat mayonnaise upside down in his uh
in his in his bed and he looks adorable
and i put a little song behind it and
and all of a sudden my video
went from uh like when i posted myself
with like a thousand views to all of a
sudden
668 000
views and i'm sitting there like oh my
cat
significantly more famous than me he
deserves it he's adorable he's the best
cat in the world but
i'm i i tic talks a strong struggle for
me but i guess i get shot if you're good
at it and you've got the following and
you know you're constantly getting the
recognition it's fun to interact with
your fans
i can see the addiction becoming very
very real and and like he said sometimes
you just take a break and good from him
for recognizing what it is and and
putting mental his mental health first
yeah and he you know when you have like
millions of followers like that too and
i feel like there is something a little
bit different with tick tock and
instagram say instagram you post about
your life tick tock i feel like you kind
of have to follow the trends you have to
really stay up to date on what songs are
trending uh certain videos are trending
uh that's just been my experience but
yeah i think i think two the more people
talk about just taking a break from
social media because you go down such a
rabbit hole and then you cut you emerge
like four hours later and you're like
right i should be doing something yeah
and i think that's it like the fact that
sean said that he takes a break like he
said jojo is so important for your
important to health and uh and how much
you actually are on it per day like i
control myself by seeing it in the
morning and once in the evening and
trying not to do it during the day but i
am obsessed with tick tock let me tell
you you're good on time because it's so
much fun it's a place where it's not
always have to be politically correct
you're right there's all these trends uh
and i'm learning a great deal about it
and you talking jojo about videos going
viral there was one video i was talking
that i did and it has over 10 million
views over a million likes one video and
then i put it on instagram and over 40
million views over a million likes it
just blew up
and it's insane what can happen but it
triggered a conversation so this is the
power of social media when you talk
about shawn mendes all these big stars
who use social media it is a platform
where you are promoting yourself in many
ways you think about the rock he doesn't
do commercials it's all on social media
so there is this major power that you
can use but also acknowledging how it's
affecting you and i think that's really
important what sean said was you know
taking that break so uh for him to do
that kudos to you because that that's
that's what his life is is being able to
promote on social media so uh but i do
love watching him on tik tok he is so
great right live and he's playing music
and jojo you need to do a live on tick
tock and and we're going to listen to
you
okay
tell me when you're here because i will
be watching uh but it is the power and
it's acknowledging yeah listen to
sangeeta she knows how to make things go
viral
okay
well no that one we're gonna get it
we're gonna do a video we'll get 10
minutes that's right
[Laughter]